[Applaudissements]
pma ou gpr
je vais le rejoindre après cet avis bon
alors je suis je suis pas parti oui
évidemment j'avais envie mais comme il y
avait plus de place aux stages croisades
en terre inconnue qu'organise 6 vitesses
à la mecque
façon moi j'ai pas les moyens en
revanche le mec à bercy qui vient de me
redresser fiscalement bon séjour aux
seychelles monsieur
façon faut être lucide à en france on
bosse la moitié de l'année pour l'état
donc là depuis le 30 juin je suis passé
fonctionnaires du secteur privé
c'est le meilleur des deux mondes le
salaire du public avec l'insécurité du
privé en gros j'ai l'impression d'être à
un flic du quai des orfèvres qui fait
des heures sup comme videur de boîte à
béziers
à la base moi les vacances je trouve ça
plutôt chouette quoi c'est vrai que moi
toute l'année je rêve de ces délicieuses
promiscuité des plages
le métro décapotable s'il ya bien une
chose que j'ai envie de retrouver sur la
côte d'azur c'est l'ambiance david price
qu'avec des gens à poil c'est vrai
mais l'été c'est aussi l'occasion de
penser aux autres quoi faut il ya par
exemple moi je m'occupe un peu de mes
grands parents là les installe dans une
morgue
c'est super pratique parce que ça fait
deux coups en à quoi tu vois d'un côté
il fait froid et si jamais il décède ils
sont déjà sur place
battus façon qu'est ce qu'on apprend en
vacances qu'on aime rien faire alors
certains disent oui moi j'en profite
pour lire faut voir ce que les gens
lisent en vacances levy musso pancol
tchad et des chefs-d'oeuvre dans
lesquelles on entre avec autant de
facilité que dans une allemande après le
passage des russes
alors du coup je suis là paris quoi je
m'occupe comme je peux bon heureusement
et à paris plage ça c'est génial d'un
mois le béton
j'adore ce à quoi c'est le souffle chaud
des bouches d'égout comme une caresse
sur la pauvreté resté coincé au péage de
l'autoroute du soleil
puis déjà il n'y a pas de chant des
cigales et ça c'est insupportable mois
le chant des cigales on dirait un
troupeau de lépreux qu'ils aient squames
la peau à l'opinel un très
bon à la nature ça me fascine pas du
tout je me dis dieu est avec vous êtes
écolo mais franchement je trouve ça
parce que la nature je la trouve pas
sympathique ou et moi je trie mes
poubelles c'est pas pour ça que quand je
vais au ski j'ai eu une semaine de beau
temps
d'ailleurs pour vider la tête je suis
allé là je fais des pâtés de sable
pendant une heure je me suis engueulé
avec un gosse qui voulaient détruire mon
château tel film le gamin il me lance si
tu me rends pas mon truc que j'appelle
mes deux papas
l'hétérophobie des mioches
non ces appareils plage tu peux faire
des trucs que tu peux pas faire à la mer
d'ailleurs j'ai nagé avec des poissons
dans la seine à c'est super agréable
quand tu peux les touches et vu qu'ils
sont morts
[Applaudissements]
et j'ai dérivé à côté d'une carte
pendant trois heures entre le
pont-des-arts et bir-hakeim j'avais
l'impression de me tirer la bourre avec
jean marc ayrault un truc
moi je suis bien que sur les quêtes
façon là parce qu'en ville en été il ya
que des touristes et des pauvres parfois
les deux ça s'appelle un chinois
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'ils sont
conséquents sans du clown sur le champ
de mars et à chinois qui me demande où
est la tour eiffel jeudi est désolé je
suis pas du 7e arrondissement
là j'ai sorti un plan du métro sncf doit
être entre douai et valenciennes
je n'ai rien contre attention j'ai rien
contre ces gens là mais ils sont pas
comme nous le dire même les chinois
réinstaller en france faut reconnaître
qu'ils sont très mal intégrés
il bosse tout le temps
ils se croient en allemagne
[Applaudissements]
à un moment là un moment
c'est toujours les maghrébins qui
prennent c'est toujours les maghrébins
alors qu'à bien des égards ils sont
beaucoup plus civilisée alors ok le
halal c'est pas un modèle d'homéopathie
bouchehr mais contrairement à la cuisine
chinoise tu sais au moins que l'animal
ont là-bas
alors pas beaumont était à paris et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux